I invest in four types of Mutual Funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international I prefer mutual
funds that have at least a 10-year track
record and all of the ones I currently
own do and I invest in those in up times
and down times in all times I never stop
I never stop I never stop I invest all
the way down I invest all the way up I
am always looking like I'm the smartest
person on the planet and the only
intelligent thing I did was I didn't
stop and I just keep investing and I
just keep investing and I just keep
investing and we've found all kinds of
research that says the number one
correlating factor to people who build
wealth investing is that they actually
invest consistent they don't sit and
discuss whether the debt ceiling is
going to knock them out